[dramatic music playing]
It's always exciting.
Sometimes there is even
between the workmen
a bit of a competition.
Who will find first?
NARRATOR: While conservators
move the painted walls
to the store rooms
for safekeeping,
Tarek spots something
in the sand.
We have a pillar.
And I can see already there is
a djed pillar decorated on it.
NARRATOR: It's an
important find.
This pillar confirms the nature
of ancient Egyptian religious
beliefs in the years after
the Amarna Revolution
and Tutankhamun's death.
This is exciting.
The deceased is appearing
now, as he would have
been carrying the djed pillar.
NARRATOR: The djeds symbol
represents the god Osiris,
who arose from the dead to live
again as king of the afterlife.
Ancient Egyptians painted the
symbol on the bottom of coffins
and wrapped the mummy
with djed amulets
to summon Osiris and rejuvenate
the soul of the deceased.
They also carved djed symbols
onto the pillars in their tombs
to follow Osiris
to the afterlife.
[mysterious music playing]
In the time of
Amarna, they told them
that there is no afterlife.
After, there was a reaction to
an extreme, worshipping Osiris.
NARRATOR: The team
has found inscriptions
to Osiris and Ptah, gods
whose worship Tutankhamun's
father had forbidden.
It's more evidence
Tutankhamun had abandoned
his father's revolution.
He had restored belief
in the afterlife
and the power of
all Egypt's gods.
The religious revolution
demanding the worship
of a single sun God was over.
This was a feat that
deserved a magnificent burial
and a majestic tomb.
So why didn't Tutankhamun's
mummy get the tomb it deserved?
In the Valley of
the Kings, Aliyah
is investigating this mystery.
Why does Ay banish
Tutankhamun to such a small
and poorly decorated tomb?
Aliyah examines Ay's
tomb to look for clues.
That's the baboon wall.
Both Tut and Ay opted
for the same scene,
almost like the same person
chose what goes in each tomb.
NARRATOR: The
uncanny similarities
between the two chambers
suggests a common hand
was at work on both.
But only Ay's tomb
was fit for a pharaoh.
It's very similar to the tomb
of Tutankhamun-- the style,
the artwork, the sarcophagus.
But it's so much bigger.
NARRATOR: The artistic
style of the two tombs
suggests that Ay may have been
responsible for decorating
both.
Investigators now suspect
that when Tutankhamun died
unexpectedly young, the lavish
tomb he ordered for himself
was not finished.
Ay seized the moment.
He ordered Tut be buried
in a smaller tomb.
It was quickly decorated
and sealed before the paint
had a chance to dry.
With Tutankhamun gone, and
before any challengers could
oppose him, Ay crowned
himself pharaoh
and decreed that
when he died, he
would take Tutankhamun's tomb.
[dramatic music playing]
Ay buried Tutankhamun
in the smaller tomb,
so he could have the
bigger tomb for himself.
This is the tomb
that was intended
for Tutankhamun, the tomb of Ay
NARRATOR: Ay banished
Tutankhamun to an unworthy tomb
to secure his place as pharaoh.
Later pharaohs
erased Tutankhamun
from history, smearing his
name as the son of a heretic.
But 100 years ago, when
his tomb was discovered,
Tutankhamun was
reborn a superstar.
Now experts use the clues to
piece together his true legacy
as a boy king dealing with
the aftermath of his father's
religious revolution.
[music playing]